I have a girlfriend now.
That's a big thing in my life, guys.
-Yeah.
-[cheering]
Yeah.
It's been four years, but, you know.
I'm admitting it publicly now!
[crowd whooping]
[chuckling]
Man, I hope we don't break up.
Yeah.
[stammers] Like, guys have a hard time
admitting that shit publicly.
Girls will do it right away.
You'll be on like the third date
and they're like, "This my man.
Back away, bitch, get the fuck away,
bitch. This is my man."
Guys'll be like a year and a half in
and be like, "Oh, yeah. I know her."
[laughter]
"Yeah, no. Yes. I've seen her around.
She's got that hair, right? Yeah."
Yeah.
Then your friend calls you out.
"Aren't you living with her?"
[laughter]
And you're like, "That's where
I've seen her around. Yeah.
That's right.
The living room area. Correct.
She does have that hair, though.
That is true."